hi my name's clay Christensen I'm a
professor at the Harvard Business School
I brought with me a set of puzzles all
related to innovation
we decided that the way we teach
marketing is at the core of what makes
motivation difficult to achieve the most
helpful way we've thought of it so far
is that we actually hire products to do
things for us and understanding what job
we have to do in our lives for which we
would hire a product is really the key
to cracking this problem of motivating
customers to buy what we're offering so
I wanted just to tell you a story about
a project we did for one of the big fast
food restaurants they were trying to
Goose up the sales of their milkshakes
they had just studied this problem up
the Gazoo they brought in customers who
fit the profile of the quintessential
milkshake consumer and they'd give them
samples and ask could you tell us how we
can improve our milkshake so you'd buy
more of them do you want it chocolatey
or cheap or chunky or chewy or they get
very clear feedback they would then
improve the milkshake on those
dimensions and it had no impact on sales
or profits whatsoever so one of our
colleagues went in with a different
question on his mind and that was I
wonder what job arises in people's lives
that caused them to come to this
restaurant to hire a milkshake so we
stood in a restaurant for 18 hours one
day and just took very careful data what
time did they buy these milkshakes what
were they wearing were they alone did
they buy other food with it did they eat
it in the restaurant or drive off with
it it turned out that nearly half of the
milkshakes were sold before 8 o'clock in
the morning the people who bought them
were always alone it was the only thing
they bought and they all got in the car
and drove off with it so to figure out
what job they were trying to hire it to
do we came back the next day and stood
outside the restaurant so we could
confront these folks as they left the
milkshake in hand and in language that
they could understand we essentially
asked excuse me please but I got to sort
this puzzle out what job were you trying
to do for yourself that caused you to
come here and hire that milkshake
and they'd struggle to answer so we
didn't help them by asking other
questions like well think about the last
time you were in the same situation
meeting to get the same job done but you
didn't come here to hire a milkshake
what did you hire and then as we put all
of their answers together it became
clear that they all had the same job to
do in the morning and that is they have
a long and boring drive to work and they
just needed something to do while they
drove to keep the commute interesting
one hand had to be on the wheel but
somebody had given him another hand and
there wasn't anything in it and they
just needed something to do while they
drove they weren't hungry yet but they
knew they'd be hungry by ten o'clock so
they also wanted something that would
just pull down there and stay for their
morning good question what a way higher
when I do this job you know I've never
framed the question that way before but
last Friday I heard a banana to do the
job take my word for it never hire
bananas they're gone in three minutes
you're hungry by 7:30 if you promise not
to tell my wife I probably hire donuts
twice a week but they don't do it well
either they're gone fast they crumb all
over my clothes they get my fingers
gooey sometimes I hire bagels but as you
know they're so dry and tasteless then I
have to steer the car with my knees
while I'm putting Jam on them and then
if the phone rings we got that crisis I
remember I hired a Snickers bar once but
ah I felt so guilty I've never hired
Snickers again let me tell you when I
come here and hire this milkshake it is
so viscous that it easily takes me 20
minutes to suck it up that thin little
straw who cares what the ingredients are
I don't all I know is I'm full all
morning and it fits right here in my cup
holder well it turns out that the
milkshake does the job better than any
of the competitors which in the
customers minds are not burger king
milkshakes but it's bananas Donuts
bagels Snickers bars coffee and so on
but I hope you can see how if you
understand the job how to improve the
product becomes just obvious